ladies and gentlemen my name is Steve
Weintraub I'm editor-in-chief of the
website collider I am thrilled to be
moderating this q a for this awesome
movie here in this awesome IMAX theater
ladies and gentlemen we have I want to
make sure I can do the order right we
have Stephen Lang Sam Worthington and
producer John Landau coming down
[Applause]
how you doing sir
I'm Max
[Applause]
what's really and by the way this is
going to be spoiler free because
obviously you guys haven't seen the
movie yet so you do not have to worry
about anything being ruined wait people
knew the ship sank
different different movie but true so
funny story about this specific theater
years ago for the first avatar I was in
London and I asked Mr Cameron hey where
when I get back to the States I want to
see Avatar in 3D in IMAX where should I
go and he said my favorite theater is
the AMC Burbank 16. there you go thank
you AMC and they they've been great
supporters of pushing what is possible
in the theaters and reminding people
just how special the big screen
experience can be
um so I saw the movie already and I
really want to know this is probably my
most important question
um how did you convince uh the studio to
let you get on a spaceship fly across
the Galaxy and film on Pandora because I
felt like I was on that planet with you
guys when I was watching well what we
did we started out with plans for the
spaceship
and uh they just they bought into it no
but I think we that that's a great the
best compliment we could have and I
think first of all it starts with the
performances that the cast gave us that
people just believe those performances
and then we challenged WETA FX I tell
people on the first movie we needed to
be photographic because you couldn't
tell me what was real on Pandora on this
movie we have so many scenes with live
action and CG elements and vice versa
and water that everybody knows what it
looks like we need to raise our standard
to being photoreal when you guys
obviously you're about to see it you'll
unders you'll see
um I love the IMAX format I think it's
the best way to see a movie I'm this
theater is phenomenal but all IMAX
theaters are phenomenal for all three of
you why is it so important for audiences
to see the film in IMAX
because it's immersive and it's a you
know it's the best quality to to immerse
you in Pandora I think that's what Jim's
always set out to do I used to transport
you
um rather than being a gimmick he's
bringing you into into his dream
I I agree with that it's the uh the at
the total uh experience uh it's uh it
just completely immersive I don't think
I can improve on that word but that's
the reason there's no experience like
the IMAX experience when it comes to you
know really encompassing the uh the
world of Pandora so it's the way to see
it
I also think it's because of how IMAX
builds their theaters you look at the
theater we're in now it's it's this
seating you're not obscured by someone
in front of you blocking your view for
the images that we spend so long to put
up on the screen
uh I think we can all agree that
Hollywood has put out some crap 3D
movies
I think I think we can all agree um
Avatar and Avatar the way of water are
not crap they are phenomenal in 3D and
it it the theatrical you cannot recreate
this at home I know this is a little bit
similar to the IMAX thing but why is it
so important for audiences to see the
film in 3D I'm just trying to take in
the compliment that we're not crap but
okay no but you know what I mean like
there was a period where Hollywood
really made a mistake with it but you
know you guys and you know Mr Cameron
have done something incredible with this
well we view 3D differently than a lot
of people we view 3D not as a a world
coming out of a window but as a window
into a world where we want the 3D to
disappear we want the screen plane to
disappear and help transport you to the
world
Jim views 3D as a tool to help guide the
audience on where to look just like in
2D a filmmaker might use Focus or
lighting or movement 3D is now one of
those elements that Jim uses to direct
the eye on the narrative storytelling
curious between the first movie in this
movie how did the cameras and Technology
change to help you tell the story well
first and foremost these guys when we
put the performances instead of wearing
a single standard definition camera they
had to wear two high definition cameras
so that we're recording a higher
definition of performance that starts
with the character then on our live
action side we upped the ante we shot
with a high dynamic range Venice cameras
that were customized for the 3D
experience we shot at 48 frames per
second and the theaters have much better
capabilities now than they ever had
before and you know it's worth noting
that that that not every film that's
made is is uh demands or is necessary to
either for the IMAX experience or for
the 3D experience whereas when Jim
conceived of this very world he
conceived of it with 3D and and I'm Max
in mind it seems to me and so you know
it's it's a it's a question of the uh
the resource completely
matching the um you know the product it
seems to me
Sam would you like to add anything no
where's that sign
uh I am curious how do you think the
sequel actually improves on the first
film
whoa look it's an extension of the first
film I think that's what Jim promised uh
swim he first talked to us about it in
uh you know 2015 was when I first got a
call and he said I can expand on the
world and not make this a carbon copy of
the first one I can expand on this
family
um and in doing so I think I can raise
the stakes of everything
um and that's what I think he's done I
think he's he found an emotional through
line which you're about to see
um that in that really ramps everything
up I think Jim is very good at that you
know he's very track record of sequels I
said stands by itself but he's his
sequel's always familiar but then he
pushes it to it to this new level and
I'm um you know we'll soon see here and
uh takes to it in no way is is it an
improvement on the first because I think
the first avatar stands alone it's still
just an excellent movie but but I think
the world now expands big time in this
and I and I would venture to say that as
the saga continues in Avatar three and
four you'll continue to see the
deepening and the expansion of that
world that's just it's just the way uh
it's the way he builds his vision it
seems to be I'm curious for all three of
you which shot in either Avatar movie do
you think was the toughest to pull off
and why I
wow look I think you'll see in this
movie and not to be a shot that you
think about
um there's there's a scene and this is
just typical of of the challenge where
spider a human character played by Jack
champion
is lamenting who his father is
and Kiri played by Sigourney Weaver but
her character is a navi comes up behind
him and hugs him
and pulls in his chest and you see the
chest she's not really there
and but when you're looking at and this
goes back to what I meant about being
photoreal
she had to look as photoreal as Spider
did you had to believe her arms pulling
around him squeezing in his muscles and
stuff that's a challenge that people
wouldn't think when they just watched
the movie they would just accept it
um
but Jim's always pushing it man there's
a saying you're about to see where
there's a reflection
so I asked Jim literally a couple of
days ago I said that to me is pretty
cool this reflection because it's a
reflection of a CG character and a
reflection of a human character going on
and he said yeah I didn't want to make
it easy on myself
was there a shot for you
well I think just the geography there's
a there's a kind of a battle royal at
the end and uh the um just the geography
of of the ship was very very challenging
to me and I remember as we began to work
on it we were it was just a difficult
thing to kind of map out we didn't know
where to plunge in but finally you know
you had no alternative but to just kind
of start doing it and we did it so that
I I find that whole sequence of shots to
be
remarkably uh shot and edited
I'm curious this is a little bit geeky
but how long is a day on Pandora as
compared to Earth
two weeks ago is there is there a
difference though look there is and Jim
would have to explain that there's a
whole cycle of Jim knows we had an
astrophysicist come in and work with us
on the orbit of Pandora around
polyphemus and and the days the best is
when my mites would come to sit I'd say
go ask Jim about the planet Pandora and
they'd go up and say oh can you tell us
a bit about the planet Pandora Jimmy go
well firstly it's a [ __ ] Moon so it's
not a planet and then it would just keep
going and you know and again my mates
would look back at me and go oh man
these guys got so much detail and I
think that's you know that's what makes
gym work is that the amount of detail
that is put into everything the
ecosystems the history the the 10-year
gap between Avatar one and never tell
way of water it's it's it's well thought
out and well constructed and all from
his head
I am curious when did you actually start
filming on avatar the way of water
capturing actually in September of 2017.
so that's when we got these guys back
and what we did even before that though
we repeated what we did on the first
movie we went to Hawaii for a rehearsal
with the cast and a sense memory you
know experience with them and we
rehearsed both in the rainforest and in
the water
and I like one of the great things we
did in Hawaii was we went on perhaps the
most Pandora experience Earth can offer
we went on a night scuba dive to the
bottom 30 feet down in darkness except
for light shining up and then out of the
Abyss
came these pandora-like creatures giant
manta rays and they swam over us and
they swam around us and we were able to
touch them and and we had trouble
getting Cliff Curtis to come to the
surface from that and and then in the
jungles when we were out there
rehearsing I saw Stephen Lang doing some
fighting with sticks with Jim and
I tell you a story about that
we were out in the jungle and we were
doing all these activities learning you
know stalking and hunting and Gathering
and things and at one point they said
okay now we're gonna go off and we're
gonna do some basket weaving and finally
finally as quartz I kind of put my foot
down and I said I'm not basket weaving I
can't see any any circumstances under
which quartz would go weave a basket
myself so everybody else went basket
weaving and I went off and I I carved a
spear for a while you know I want to
tell the story of Sam I don't know if
you're going to remember this story from
the first movie
we went to Hawaii we were rehearsing in
the rainforest and yeah I'll admit it
Sam was in a really bad looking ponytail
wig and he was you know wearing a little
you know shorts like a you know like
they see a loincloth in the movie and
jam had a little handheld like Sony
camera and all of a sudden there's a guy
walking his dog
do you remember this and then the guy
goes to say what are you doing I said
we're making a movie with James Cameron
God did Titanic and he looked at Jim
with the Handycam and went he's going
[ __ ] downhill from there isn't he
exactly
that is a that's a great story
uh so I'm curious as a fan how much of
Avatar two three four five how much of
that have you guys actually filmed
Don is first of all we've completed all
four scripts for for two three four and
five they've read them they know where
their characters go they know it informs
how they play these scenes we went out
and we shot all of movie two
we shot 95 percent of movie three we
have a little bit that we have to still
pick up and we shot the First Act of
movie four
and so the plan from what I understand
and I think Jim has said this is that
you guys have to make sure they're still
an audience for Avatar to make sure you
can actually finish four and five
I'm planning on finishing four and five
there's going to be an audience we're
going to finish those movies those those
are stories I think really you've read
the scripts I mean each movie comes to
its own emotional as resolutions I said
but movie five really drives it home
yeah yeah
I know that people in this audience are
definitely curious about the I know
we're here to talk about way of water
but I like asking about future things so
what can you tease if anything about the
third fourth and fifth movie in terms of
what audiences can look forward to
more of everything I think one of the
great things that we've done and Jim has
done in these scripts is each movie is
going to take you to new biomes but and
new cultures and I think one of the
things that Avatar has is this idea of
inate kamea I see you and it's not about
seeing you for who you physically are or
what you look like it's about seeing you
from the inside and the idea that we get
to introduce new diverse Clans that look
different than the omadakaya and send a
message that you know about a metaphor
for our world and accepting people for
who they are on the inside and not
judging them by who they are on the
outside
thank you
uh Sam I think you said uh recently that
Jim wrote a script for Avatar 1.5 which
takes place obviously between the two
films how did that script and what you
learned in that script in inform how you
played uh in Avatar 2 and Dawn there's a
missing Gap
that's basically what it was a a I'm too
scared to tell you what's in it in case
arrows come out of the dark from the
boss but but it was it did fill in a lot
of stuff it filled it filled in what
happened when the when all the sky
people left and it I think Jim wrote it
and then realized okay this is just
about them being heroic Warriors and
continuing this battle and I think it it
forced once he wrote it and it's a full
script it was you know many people would
have been astonished that the detail in
it and how long it took him and many
many filmmakers would have took that and
said I'm just going to make that he just
used it as a bouncing off point to
realize well I want to make this story
more about family than about being
Heroes you know and that's what led him
to continue to continue where the Saga
goes franchise plug franchise plug that
story is now available on Dark Horse
Comics as High Ground so go check it out
I did not know that uh Stephen I'm
curious how did you get ready to play
the antagonist in this movie versus
playing the antagonist in the first film
well in in the first film uh the the
mission for me was just to get as big
and as powerful physically as I possibly
could and uh get into the that kind of
marine headspace that courts and habits
you know and and and that's what I did
and I just I just worked out like a
demon and and that's what I did but
however then but then coming into this
one the way of water quartz has gone
he's changed a bit he's become
reconstituted and and uh the ways of uh
of water have entered into his into his
very DNA and so he tries he understands
that that the way he went about his
business the first time didn't quite
work out as intended so he needs to
adapt and he does begin to adapt to the
ways of of Pandora itself he becomes
more I think a much more fluid character
in his movements uh less uh he he always
had moved in kind of straight lines and
he thought in straight lines as well but
now with that kind of a Pandora
influence going on inside him I think he
probably more he can operate more
effectively uh you know in that in that
environment so the choices that you know
I I made or or we kind of you set up
circumstances as you work hurry up man
they want to see the film so choices can
make themselves or
um uh now I lost my train of thought
watch the movie he's right
[Applause]
I don't know
foreign
process because that's where everything
comes together I'm curious the movie's
over three hours how long was oh wait
wait wait two hours and 72 minutes
my bad I apologize you're right it is
two hours and 72 minutes but I am
curious what what was it like in the
editing room bringing this Beast Down to
the run time you had did you end up with
a lot of deleted scenes was it a painful
edit to try to get it to this length you
know it's it's a painful edit because
because these guys give us such great
performances and when you sit there and
you look at the hole you know what you
want to create is a hole that is greater
than the sum of the parts and every
scene that we would look at stood out
and said that's a great scene that's a
great scene and it wasn't until we had
enough of the whole picture that we
could really look at and go okay let's
chisel here let's chisel here let's
preserve this performance and we lost
some really great moments but we think
we ended up with the right length
telling the right story
on that note I'm going to con agree with
what you just said you guys are about to
watch something awesome and on that note
I really want to give a huge thank you
to Stephen Lang Samoa and I want to
thank all of you for being people who go
to the movie theaters seeing things on
the big screen keep doing it thank you
[Applause]